The voyage of the Parker Solar Probe
is about to begin.
Its seven-year mission:
To boldly go where no craft has gone before.
To touch the sun.
To seek out answers to questions like:
Why is the sun’s corona so dang hot?
[music]
Smaller and speedier than starships past,
NASA’s Parker Solar Probe is set to blast off
from Cape Canaveral aboard a Delta IV Heavy rocket —
the largest in NASA’s arsenal.
After clearing Earth’s atmosphere,
Parker will shed its rocket
and get one last boost.
Then, spring-loaded gadgets
that were stowed for launch emerge.
Solar panels pop out and start charging,
the cooling system revs up,
and antennas and other instruments
stretch out into space.
Six weeks after launch, Parker reaches Venus.
It’ll use Venus’ gravity
to slingshot itself toward the sun.
Another six weeks later,
Parker becomes the first spacecraft
to enter the sun’s outer atmosphere or corona.
The corona is actually hotter
than the surface of the sun.
But a pancake-shaped heat shield
keeps all of Parker’s gadgets
a little above room temperature.
Most of the spacecraft’s solar panels also
tuck behind the carbon composite shield
to avoid melting.
Traveling at high speeds will prevent Parker
from getting pulled into the sun.
As the probe surfs the sun’s atmosphere,
it’ll gather important intel on solar radiation,
electric fields, magnetic fields, and particles.
The data could help explain
what heats up the corona
and how solar wind escapes the sun
and accelerates through the solar system.
Then Parker swoops back out to cold, dark space
and transmits its data back to Earth.
It’ll do the same thing 23 more times,
sweeping by the sun every 88 days.
Venus will give the probe six more slingshot assists,
and each time, it will inch closer
to the sun’s surface.
While Parker is close to the sun,
it won’t be able to radio home,
so the probe will have to fly solo.
Tiny solar sensors tell the craft
to shimmy left or right
when they’re exposed to too much sun.
Parts of Parker will get hit with
475 times the solar radiation that
spacecraft experience in orbit around Earth.
The probe’s final three orbits will take it within
6.3 million kilometers of the sun’s surface.
That’s seven times closer than
the current record holder, Helios 2 back in 1976.
On its final orbit,
Parker will also come in fast and furious
at a top speed of 690,000 kilometers per hour
or 190 kilometers per second.
It’ll be the fastest human-made object
in the solar system.
At that speed,
you could travel from New York to Tokyo
in under a minute.
So, top that, Vin Diesel.
The mission is set for seven years,
but it could go longer.
Whenever Parker meets its end,
it’ll go out in a blaze of glory.
Once the probe runs out of fuel,
most of it will burn up
in the very star it was sent to study.
But not the heat shield —
that giant carbon disk will continue to orbit the sun
for millions of years.
[music]